alors le questionnaire votre laurent
fabius votre mot préféré la douceur mots
que vous détestez la calomnie votre
drogue favorite le chocolat au lait le
son le bruit que vous aimez les spas et
des rires des enfants le matin quand il
passe devant ma chambre et qui vont
prendre leur petit déjeuner ils sont le
bruit que vous détestez la lime à ongles
votre juron gros mot blasphème favori
merde
typiquement français là et or là c'est
d'ailleurs parce que là on n'a pas pu en
parler mais je me dire que vous êtes le
le représentant vous êtes le député du
grand québec est une circonscription
très ouvrière et en même temps vous avez
fait toutes vos études ou de 30 ans se
passe au trocadéro dans le 16e
arrondissement à la il ya un personnage
double j'ai appris énormément que
milliers le des gens m'ont apporté
beaucoup j'essaie d'apporter mais je
trouve que la voix de jurons à mon avis
rassemble le trocadéro au grand quévilly
merde mon avis il avoue fait la liaison
entre le alors homme ou femme pour
illustrer de vos billets de banque
jean jaurès le métier que vous n'auriez
pas aimé faire trafiquant
trafiquants c'est par amitié de plus en
plus ses abords
et d'y mettre bon ordre comme bédié pour
lui une liste laplante l'arbre l'animal
dans lequel vous aimeriez être réincarné
cheval sauvage un cheval sauvage assez
intéressant préférez les chevaux
sauvages qu'on peut pas ce qu'on ne peut
pas monter plutôt que s'il ya la
dimension de la crinière aussi et enfin
si dieu existe qu'aimeriez vous après
votre mort lorient laurent fabius vous
entendre dire par dieu vient assieds toi
mon fils et dis moi ce que tu voudrais
faire dans cette période un peu nouvelle
qui s'ouvre à s'intéressant tout de
suite déjà donc le travail et l'ambition
ambitions et ça repart il sera parti on
franchit les effets assez incroyable
réponse très intéressante
ange archange étape
[Musique]